- We have our first question from Juan.
Thank you for sending in another question.
We, I remember hearing from you last week.
So, Juan wants to know if the study is
longitudinal, since...
- [Odaelys] I think
Jeanne went out for a bit.
- [Pedro] Oops did we lose Jeanne?
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- That's all right, I can take over.
Well, let me start by once
again thanking you Odaelys,
that was a really really
fantastic presentation.
And, I'll pick up from
where Jeanne left off,
on the question from Juan,
who is asking if the
study was longitudinal
because the sample size has changed
between each range of phase
that you were showing.
- So the--
- [Jeanne] I'm back.
- Oh!
- [Jeanne] Yeah, sorry.
(group laughs)
We all face internet problems, right?
I think that this question actually is
like why are there different
numbers of patients.
Like its not the same--
- It's not.
And because they are looking at,
they're asking a different questions.
So in that first figure that I showed you
where they're just
looking at the presence,
or the detectable amounts of antibodies.
They are looking just to see
if all of the 285 patients,
if they're able to see if they
have IgM or IgG antibodies.
Now, out of those patients,
you can't really look
at when the time course
of the production of the antibodies.
So they then took out data sets
where they have multiple serum samples.
So about 200 of the patients,
they only had one blood
sample from the patient
that they are able to analyze from,
and from that one sample you can only see,
"Oh I see IgM, oh I see IgG",
and they use that in a particular graph.
In the other data sets
where they are looking
at it from being negative
for certain antibodies to being positive,
(birds chirping)
they can only use the ones
that they have multiple serum samples.
So yes,
the samples differ based on the questions
that they were trying to ask.
I think that--
- [Jeanne] Cool, thanks, and Odaelys,
I can hear your bluejays in your backyard.
- Ooh yeah, I know I've been like--
I've been using the phone
to detect what birds are--
- [Jeanne] So loud (laughs), yeah
- [Pedro] Isn't it lovely though?
- Yes it is actually.
- Okay well let's go
for question two then,
from Urania Davis who asks
how long the IgG needs to be present
in order for us to
consider a patient immune.
- We have no idea.
(laughs)
And so yeah we're really trying,
well not me in particular,
but scientists are really
trying hard to figure out
if one, does it-- is there difference with
how much IgG antibodies you're producing?
Does it matter if the IgG antibodies
are neutralizing or not?
And also do the antibodies
do seem to decrease overtime?
And so because this is a recent situation,
we don't have the samples necessary,
to kinda answer that question.
And so if someone's been
infected in February,
it's only been what,
three months?
- [Pedro] Yeah.
- And so we can't really predict
what their immune system is
gonna do in the next six months.
But based on other infections
that are similar to SARS-CoV-2,
like SARS and MERS,
immunity seems to be around a year or two.
So scientists are kinda going off of that,
but once again we're still unsure.
- [Pedro] That's great.
Well, we'll move on to question three then
from Joan Gensert.
He asks about subtypes of IgGs.
- Yes they are I think of...
- [Pedro] You should talk
a little bit about this.
- Yeah, so you're getting
really nitty gritty.
So they are I think four subtypes of IgG.
The authors do not indicate
what subtypes they are.
I briefly read something,
no, I think that was something else.
I'm not sure if I've read a paper that
specified the subtype of
IgG that they're looking at.
It may be in the new paper
that Rockefeller University put out,
because they actually
did a sequence analysis
of all the antibodies that are produced,
and I'm pretty sure they
might have a better idea
of what those subtypes of IgG are.
And, so there are clonal differences
with the IgG antibodies that are produced,
and these clonal differences
do seem to have a connection with
how good they are at
neutralizing infection.
But that's a good question.
- All right cool.
I think related maybe is Joan asks again,
was there a correlation between
the different seroconversion
times, I think
and the deaths versus survival
or released from the hospital.
And that's an interesting question
cause we didn't actually see
some correlation--
- Samples, yeah.
So from the paper,
I don't think they,
I don't think any of the
patients succumbed to infection.
So I don't know the answer to that,
so they did not follow the patients
after their release from the hospitals.
So I can't, I can't actually
answer that question
based on what the authors presented, yeah.
- This is an important question
and I think you know folks are on it
and hopefully we'll get more data,
-- give a bigger
picture of that later on.
- [Pedro] Okay, that's great
and Aditi is back with another question.
Question five for the day.
She asks if the IgG
antibodies are specific
to spike proteins or if
they're just a general
response of the virus.
That's a really good question.
- Yeah, that is a good question.
So with the IgG antibodies,
so in this particular test,
the assay that they use,
the antigen that they use to detect
the IgG and IgM antibodies,
is an antigen that has both
parts of the spike protein,
and parts of the nuclear protein.
And so it they're kinda
like lumping them in one.
So these are showing
that you can get IgG antibodies response
to the spike protein
and the nuclear protein,
but I'm unsure of the
other parts of the virus.
So it is specific,
and I'm not sure if
correlates with the different
types of IgG subtypes
that you're producing
or clonal antibodies
that you're producing.
It's a good question.
- Yeah, I think there's a test
that some folks that have produced.
I don't know who made this test,
but there's a test
that's an antibody test that's
specific to the N protein,
which is the nucleocapsid protein
that surrounds the RNA
and then the one that you talked about
which is specific to the S protein.
- So there are some
and I think the paper
addressed this a little
where they looked at cross reactivity of,
I think it's the N protein
of both SARS-CoV-1 and SARS-CoV-2,
and there seems to be
slight cross reactivity
with a couple of the sample sets.
So they way they develop the assay
to bypass any like false positives,
they incorporated a peptide
that incorporates parts of
the N and parts of the S,
so they can weed out any
of the false positive
of antibodies that may
be there from a previous
SARS-type infection and
not the current SARS-CoV-2.
The test I think right now
that Quest Diagnostic is using
and the one that I spoke about in,
in my first presentation they
were using the spike protein
for those antibody tests
and I think the majority that,
or the few that FDA has
approved for emergency purposes,
do use that as protein.
Or the spike protein.
For the antibody testing.
- [Jeanne] Yeah it's so weird,
one of the things I learnt
through this whole process
is how amazing antibodies are,
like I'm like,
"Oh great, they developed
an antibody test".
It never even occurred to me that
to ask, is this the right antibody test?
(laughs)
- [Pedro] Yeah.
- I feel like my mind is
blown through all of this.
- Yeah, no it's a lot.
The immune response,
the immune system,
the human body is fascinating.
Right, and then we're also combating that
with a fascinating virus.
And so I think it's like a Catch-22
trying to understand both.
- I know, I feel a little bit bad about
the level of excitement of science
I feel around something
that's so destructive to humans.
You know it's just like weird balance.
The amount of--
- As a cancer, yeah.
As a cancer researcher I can
definitely relate to that.
- [Jeanne] Yeah, for sure.
Great, so we have a question from Marva,
- [Odaelys] Hey Marva.
(laughs)
- [Jeanne] I think that you're friends.
Can neutralizing antibodies
be made in the lab?
- [Odaelys] That's a really good question.
So that paper that I pointed out
in the end that Rockefeller
put out about a week ago,
through the pre-print bioRxiv,
their goal is to somehow,
or is to make these antibodies in the lab.
So what they're looking at,
they're looking at the different patients.
They're looking at their antibodies.
They're sequencing the
antibodies that they're have,
and they're trying to use that sequence
to produce the same antibodies
that seem to have really high
neutralizing capabilities.
And so if we can pretty
much replicate those
really strong neutralizing antibodies
that patients have produced
in their immune systems,
we can make more of that in the lab
to use as drug targets.
So that's exactly
what scientists at Rockefeller
are working on right now.
So yeah, we can.
- Yeah, I think it's the
Nussenzweig lab system--
- [Odaelys] Yeah Nussenzweig--
- So look up Michel Nussenzweig's work.
They've been asking for people.
There was a clinical study
and it might still be ongoing,
that if anybody's recovered from COVID-19,
they wanna see what
your antibodies are like
so that they can base therapies
off of the super antibody producers.
Right, so that's really--
it's all of that coming together.
You know yeah.
- It's kinda of relates to
some of the sort of earlier,
I don't know if people
are still working on that,
but some of the earlier studies of people
who were trying to get
serum out of patients,
who have recovered to use as
therapeutic itself, right?
- [Odaelys] Mm-hmm yeah,
so you're having patients who,
and I think the thought was like
if you had really bad
symptoms and you recovered,
that there's a high likelihood
that you have really good antibodies.
So they were asking patients
to donate their blood samples,
so personally I have
someone close to me who
had COVID-19 and her
doctor asked her like,
"Hey, can we have some of your blood
so we can use your serum?",
hopefully to use it as a
treatment for other patients.
So, that's the whole idea behind it.
- Yeah, same for me.
I have a very close friend
who's actually a nurse.
And has been working in the ICUs,
who ended up with COVID
and she came from this from
the angle of watching first hand people,
you know suffer and many
not recover from the disease
and she was like take my blood
and do everything you can with it.
So, I think people are really looking to
to donate and under the circumstances.
- [Pedro] Yeah, it's great
that people are being that active as well.
- [Jeanne] So thank you to everybody
who's doing that by the way.
- [Pedro] Absolutely, okay.
We have another question from Joan
who asks if the samples
were collected postmortem
and if there's a tissue
bank of these samples.
- [Odaelys] Postmortem
meaning after they--
- [Pedro] I think on patients
that died from COVID,
or was it--
- [Odaelys] So not in this paper.
- Okay.
- So, all these samples were taken
once they were in the hospital.
So they were admitted into the hospital.
I guess they signed a consent
to be a part of this clinical study,
and they took how much ever
samples they were able to take.
That could be one or that
could be a series of three
like I mentioned,
but they haven't mentioned
using samples that's from
people who passed from COVID-19,
and I'm not sure if there's
a tissue bank of samples,
I don't know.
That's a good question, I'm not sure.
- (mumbles) putting that together.
- [Odaelys] Yeah.
- [Pedro] That's good.
But all of the patients
that were used in this trial
were patients who survived then.
- Yeah, so they were all hospitalized
and at some point they were all
released from the hospital.
- [Jeanne] Great!
Well thank you so much for presenting.
I think that's all the questions we have.
- [Pedro] Yeah that's
what I was checking now.
- [Jeanne] Yeah I put the,
so there was a question around
giving the link to the Rockefeller papers,
so that's there.
And I think that's fairly,
I think we're pretty good.
One of the things that I
really loved about this paper
is the power,
you know I think we all feel
that like statistics
must involve, you know,
in order for us to make
kind of like real clinical,
like recommendations or suggestions,
it requires hundreds of
thousands of data points,
which I think for like
medications that we all
you know we can't have a,
you know a cold and flu medication
that's specific to our
bodies at this point in time,
though in cancer we wanna
have individualized, right?
And so there's sort of this push and pull
between the aggregate data
and understanding how the trends are,
so that we can predict what
happens in a population,
versus the individual response,
I think is a really fascinating way
to approach the science here.
- And even like if we're looking
at the combined data set
and the aggregate data.
It's really nice because,
like the bioRxiv
paper from Rockefeller,
they're pinpointing individuals
who have this really high
neutralizing antibody response,
and using that particular individual
to utilize that for a population.
And so I think both are very important
for us to look at the
population on a whole,
but also if we can pinpoint someone
who has like,
you know slightly outlier
that we can hijack some
of their mechanisms
to utilize for the rest of the population.
- Yeah am just thinking also
historically when you look at outliers.
Like as an example,
there was a set of outliers
in like an island over
in the South Pacific,
that helped us to understand like
HDL metabolism, right?
And sometimes these genetic outliers
are open up doors for us to understand
some new phenomenon about the human body.
So it's really good that we
are taking all this data in,
and that there's people
who can try to make sense of it
in some way, shape, or form.
And the style,
and applying the different
styles of reasoning,
on to a question so that
there're multiple angles
being explored for any specific question.
I think is really important as well.
- And the fact that it's,
you know as you mentioned earlier,
such a strong collaborate of effort
involving different
hospitals and everything,
which is such an
important part of science.
- [Jeanne] Yeah,
any last words Odaelys
to share about the paper
or anything like this?
- No, I don't have any other comments.
Or questions.
- So there is one actually, one
more question from Facebook.
And it's around IgMs versus,
I guess it's maybe IgMs
and I'm assuming it's in the
context of IgM versus IgG.
It says here,
IgM's lower, you know,
and maybe we can talk about--
- Yeah, hey Ferdi.
So,
so, I think one of the main takeaways,
is that IgM seems to be maybe important
for triggering the response for IgG.
I don't know if there's a way
that we can prevent the lowering,
or if that would help.
Because even when IgG, IgM is lowered,
you're still getting production of IgG.
And I think the important takeaway is
that we want the IgG levels,
and it doesn't seem to be
that IgM may be that important for like,
you know combating this infection well,
and that's just me thinking
about all the other papers
that I've read.
Maybe, scientists are realizing
that it does have another role to play.
But I'm not sure, yeah.